this video is brought to you by
expressvpn and Shopify people more on
them after the
reaction what is happening there
citizens of the reject Nation we are
here to continue Reacher season 2
episode 4 today John how are you jacked
up I am jacked up or Ro wait man oh
you're a
NE swan song of puns thisit we shooting
this not in the am but the PM anyway
guys we've remembered character names I
think listen everyone it would be great
if you could leave a like on this video
that'd be very much appreciated also
tell us in the comments what are your
thoughts on episode 4 be sure to
subscribe click the notification Bell
cuz we are going of course cover the
rest of Reacher season 2 thank you to
all have join us at our patreon page for
Reacher and for also you know being
understanding to our open opinions if we
are critical about some things you know
I know this is a very sensitive show for
people people are very sensitive about
their violence
full L Reaction watch single with your
own copy of reer do available for super
sexy Rejects and over there John and I
cover several things exclusively with
high list and watch Longs included John
let's get into
action go to Jack
Diner I got nothing too no new
information well I wouldn't say we
haven't found any new information damn
look at all that brand deals look
someone's got to say it was Swan working
with these guys or with these guys
Swan's not dirty Swan's totally dirty
come on reard one of them has to be you
don't think there's even a chance no I
don't focus on what we found yeah can't
doubt a member of the 1110th no matter
what joke I made a minute
ago
Brad Stacy this is a brad that is a
Fastener Jack
Fastener Brad
Reacher Shane l
director of security maybe he's a guy I
got on the phone in Atlantic City he's a
security boss and bosses give orders and
the guys we killed had orders to take us
out just a theory it's really specific
good theory aren't you the guy that said
that assumptions kill well you're
assuming that Swan's the same guy was
back in the 110 oo this is the guy
Richard chased down outside of cian's
house associate Security Officer he was
a security officer maybe there's a
reason new age has so many security
issues don't forget Marlo Burns she knew
she was sending us right into a buz saw
when she gave us europian address that
[__] we got over 1,000 employees how
are we going to tackle that machine gun
yeah let's get them all in a headlock
one at a
time one at a time there a lot of
patience at the 110 100 episodes
later that was a good opening scene yeah
I like how there's forming a tension
between them and an hour later the place
is hit with a smash and grab do you know
how that makes this apartment look like
we're five steps behind everything I
made those applications when I had
enough for a warrant looks like Wilson
Fisk he
does this his Origins who's the
monster and I'll bet you that it is
those Tin Soldiers that you were
supposed to be keeping your black eye on
it wasn't the Army brats I made it
crystal clear to them not to color
outside the line so they listened I bet
you gave them the crayons and everything
you thought if you told them nicely that
play along your NYPD these are Pi for
Christ sakes it is this too much for you
Russo Lieutenant all fairness they
immediately disobeyed would you please
go and find out what they learned right
am I asking you nicely enough Russo damn
I'm just trying to do the right thing
you know I just trying to do the right
thing get your at me check it's making
me agitated who put this song on you got
beef with the Talking Heads we're in New
York they're a New York band they're a
Rhode Island band that moved to New York
and no I don't have a beef with them
ouch Ro to Nowhere when we're sitting
here getting nowhere it's a good ironic
pull I might have something I've been
scrubbing the drives for everything Swan
related and Marlo Burns David burn he's
the assistant director of security so
all of his emails have lsten his boss
and a half dozen other security
personnels you seed on them mean they a
team they share information but he
didn't share everything yeah multiple
emails between Swan and our old friend
Marlo Burns just them no one else copied
how about what
music messages I was listening to an
album the other day thought you might
like it Jimmy Hendrick axis bold as love
axis bold as love Swan hated Hendrix
Swan became dewy Finn skinnard no
Hendrix no Zeppelin No who I mean that
was his rule he's leaving everyone else
off the email saying he loved something
we know he hated they did have that very
specific flashback about the guitar
songs yeah says the sixth track is
called little
hold
on he's in this
table file on a federal defense project
called Little Wing by far the biggest
contract ever had four times the size of
anything I've seen anywhere else in
their records h a nine figure contract
people murdered for
Less look at this in her office who's
that seems a test for the Ling Tech sell
for some military breast even a senator
but what kind of test and where and how
can I get it Senator Malcolm Lavoy
assured he would do all he could to get
the Congressional votes to make little
wing a reality and I quote he fully
believes in the work we're doing here at
New Age and we'll do whatever it takes
to help us whatever it takes you know
this guy by reputation in DC Lavoy
what's known as a paper bag his politics
and his vote go whichever way the winds
blowing ouch so if New Age stands to
make a fortune on a government contract
and Lavoy is its champion in Congress it
stands to reason new age is the wind
blowing the voice bag that sounds
wrong so Swan who's missing Maybe dirty
Maybe not is code texting Marlo Burns
who tried to have us killed about a
program supported by an ethically
compromised politician thank you thank
you some that information was a little
hard to keep up with really appreciate
you there
Dixon English
please paage bills a legislative record
they don't read that stuff they just
vote the way they're told to but as
legislative director they're the guys
who actually craft and draft the laws
which is good for us because those guys
have no security detail oo that wow that
seems like it should be different why
would those people talk to us I can make
it so they' be begging to tell us what
they know oh this is your episode man
there's a lot of powerful people in DC
with uh confidential problems things
they do in private that they'd rather
not get made public my job is to make
sure that their personal business stays
personal I need to hire you oh yeah
you're a fixer
hey you give me 10 minutes to make some
phone calls I'll get the name of the
legislative director and an ailles heel
o they're playing dirty dirt
Reacher clean if he wasn't he wouldn't
have disappeared like the rest of the
guys but he didn't disappear like the
rest of the guys his body was never
found his place wasn't trash he bought a
Hendrick's album he ran off so fast
because he knew three pissed off
soldiers and a Kaiju were coming for
him Reacher Legacy of monster I would
love love that maybe we don't know some
people as well as we think we do there's
no way the Tony Swan I recruited is a
part of this but this is a reflection on
me you're judging me I take full
responsibility for his actions in the
present there's still a hell of a lot of
work ahead more rest to be made
infrastructure dismantle whole networks
of cargo plays jeeps and helicopters
across three continents can we go back
investigation you can you could probably
discover a there so much more money I
can make oh dude cut me in on that looks
like we got some Ivory soap over here
Reacher meaning this [__] so pure and
floats how pure 99% Heisenberg let me
try it yeah
it's quite the buying bust kilos of
poison and a handful of scumbag dealers
off the streets these are the small
fish we'll catch the shark soon enough I
want to see Reacher take a shark so this
has got to be the case that's caught up
to them in the present right yeah it's
got to be something to do with this 20
months already into his terrible to
apparently he's a prodigy talking about
a prodigy you're about to hit your
bicardi milstone 151 cases closed damn
cardi reach how much is 48 brickworth
anyway 47 one's missing there's 47 not
48 in an investigation Details Matter
hey hey I said that's my quote
now I know we loaded 48 bricks into
Swan's ride oh what let's check your car
what wow sounds like this flashback
could have been brought up by other
people
solved I was saving this for later
Fallen back there when I was driving and
gotten stuck that's the first rounds on
me tonight for
that I don't know
man talk about a up yeah slack
Reacher losing a key of H I'd say that's
worth two rounds ne's been suspicious
forever and Jack's been like I recruited
him I mean he doesn't make mistakes I
make no poor assessments ever of people
no he did a thorough job there never a
character twist in my life
my gut tells me he's a good man your
gut's never been wrong before gut
Reacher you just say things now don't
even rhyme it doesn't have to rhyme the
syllables can work as well it's about
the meter according to a top comment in
our last video all right only Rhymes
poetry is only rhyme let's just see what
odonnell found yeah let's see what
odonnell found apparently odonnell found
just a syllable is good enough now for
our puns it's about the meter as much as
it is the r okay oh my gosh wow
wow I read your intake and upon first
glance I got to say got a few
questions when you're quite a handsome
fell now I'm not here to tell you how to
live your life but are you really
certain you want me to give you a new
face I only take on ugly people yeah in
a manner of
speaking wow now do the surgery yes yeah
while someone else is doing a surgery to
fix this wound on you when you're a
doctor you know what's happening your
trick here is separate blood is entering
your lungs you're drowning your brain is
deprived of oxygen oh my god I've always
wanted to kill someone like this where
you're like telling them what's
happening to them as they dying oh now
you can't hear me
now I am you you're dead beautiful
continue the monologue though this is
the most hilarious plan I've ever seen
guys he saw an advertisement in the in
middle of a very serious situation and
when I'm just going to pretend to be
him that's how good he is he just sets
himself up for success by winding up in
these situations best flat ever I love
it I want a whole spin-off where he just
takes over this guy's life Daniel Boyd
Senator Lavoy legislative director
spoiled [__] who's never lifted
anything heavier than a Grey Goose
bottle in his life Gray Goose gray
Reacher I did it you know I'm going to
go back and call some of these and I'm
going to come up with detailed defenses
and now he drafts legislation that
decides to fade of the Free World
telling his boss to vote on whatever
benefits the lobbyist who woed him best
so he was born somewhere between third
and home base and never heard the word
consequence still got the casino shirt
Boyd's going to be in Boston tonight for
a fundraiser event at the pops we'll set
him up like a bowling
[Music]
pin come on can't ghost people Jack oh
you pick up the phone I thought maybe
you couldn't answer because you broke
your hand when you drove the [__] car
through the office building I didn't get
hurt at
all the car belong belonged to one of
their employees I was
returning yep yep yep yep I want
everything you got on new AG that's why
I answered the phone this time I
actually have a reason to talk to
you I'm going to send you their security
team roster run background check see
what connections these guys have Jack
Checker before we head north uh Dixon
and I should go talk to Marlo Burns step
on her neck a little bit address is
online while we do all the work what are
you guys going to do oh we're going to
go score some drugs yeah crackery
hey not bad not bad I thought it 20
minutes ago yeah and I forgot to say it
earlier see start scripting them out in
advance we looks like Brad pther ow yeah
were we walking in Fight
[Music]
Club save that for later find a new line
of work [__] yeah man jack [__]
[Music]
reer now you're just mocking me G now
you're just mocking
me oh good shot
[Music]
though I want them to just walk in the
house and go oh nothing let's
go after this amazing shot
wow this really is like an amazing shot
drones a really open it's like a real
estate commercial
damn that amazing
shot a lightly used Craftsman mini
Mansion who sent those Roses or FL
flowers cereal yeah hey what's in the
get out here we got what need I need the
proofs of
purchase someone's scamming the prize
system she's got a kid oh a kid take the
well I sure yeah house
clear affirmative wow one 10 really
doesn't keep in touch with each other no
didn't even know I had a
kid mean just some expensive jewelry
Marlo Left Behind think she bugged out
oh Marlo thought this was someone
else Jane's a
gamer o what we got we got Crash
Bandicoot yeah she said Kaiju earlier
and just kaai you on the wall yeah look
at that kids kids behind
this $50
million thank you for your business Dr
we have a wonderful
Drive oh say something cool a little
girl what is this sensitivity with with
the children that he applies it's a very
unique character
trait do you know why I love comic books
so much here we
go mom mom didn't give a [__] it's cuz
his parents were both killed at the
comic book store hey where are the
clothes you wearing garbage garbage why
I'm already carrying boots if I had any
more clothes pretty soon I need a
suitcase I got a suitcase I need a house
to keep it in and I need a car for the
driveway anyone ever diagnosed you as a
sociopath
diagnosed
no like their awkward
chemistry the not one word holy [__]
you I'm just saying you look nice you
both look nice you look like the
[__] on top of a wedding
cake pay you back in a month when my
pension land your won't cover that suit
or the hotel room or the plane ticket
I'll pay you back in two months I got
good Pion e no guys stop everyone ready
let's go listen to some boring ass music
let's do
that oh I know oh your mouth BOS your
catchup
flies oh I hope she's on the level I
like how he's stunned like as it already
yeah but it's such a braz i' never
noticed how like oh my God he's feeling
awkward in front of the team it's not
saying you can't admire her being awe of
her beauty in the move but it was like
stunned in a way as if he has like whoa
I've never realized I found you this
attractive
before man his grew three sizes today I
don't know if I have orchestra seats or
floor box seats and I actually don't
even know what that means you mind the
mezanine that's where you are but that
just simply won't cut it you see you
want to be down here oh the sound just
wraps around you like a fleece wow why
would I swap your ticket with my Aid
when he arrives wouldn't he mind not if
he wants to keep his job please take a
seat it's how I broker all my deals in
Washington that a
quit got 13 14s 813 over 7 months 6 day
working weeks maybe a time sheet clock
in hours maybe a rating scale I don't
know this is why chat gbt exists guys
feed it into the
machine chat GP teacher ha it's a tally
13 14 something happened 13 times when
it was supposed to happen 14 times I
hear 11 out of 13 8 out of 11 okay hey I
just so they're not hey what did I tell
you answer for helping I'm going to put
a line next to all them apologize to
your brother share your Legos okay I
love you a there were 2,197 total events
whatever they were but they only
succeeded
1,547 times oh look how many times they
didn't get the outcome they wanted 2,197
-
1,547 math rer 650 at 100K each it's all
connected somehow hands are for
helping you have brass knuckles in your
pocket I got a PAW Patrol Band-Aid in
playground sent
too I am no longer my own man and you
wouldn't trade it for anything in the
world not for $65 million you are a
changed man O'Donald $65 million you get
like five kids and three lives yeah so
many houses and PAW Patrol Band-Aids buy
some land start a family be a good dad
if I had land I'd get four or five four
or five dogs no woman not even Dixon buy
a Dix
she's a
friend
okay whatever you say that was some
dress
though I love a
dress I love a dress I love a dress I
like what the characters do for Jack cuz
he's he's more personal and they could
also get to his more vulnerable aspects
that make him tense up a little
bit oh you're all R up what can I say
classical music it cats my motor running
really be Razer let's have a little PR
first you're not messing around all
right
wonderful never know how thick or thin
to make
these ladies first oh no you did the
work you get the
reward wow well played you got to try
before I can bring you on as a
[Music]
dealer
Co
[Music]
no
yes did not see that coming sweet
they're not my drugs which drugs the
ones on your mirror or up your nose best
show
ever and I know that woman in the car
wasn't Mrs Boyd and I have a special
distaste for people who don't appreciate
the sanctity of marriage yeah because
his wife
died but when I ran your name in the
system is set off bells and whistles at
the local FBI office oh no they sent a
couple of their boys down here just to
talk to you and it seems they don't care
who your boss is oh
yeah what up FBI fake lawyer agent Jack
margra oh never mind margrave this is
special agent Blake Lieutenant Oscar
Finley Jack
margrave I just got that
excellent Mar Graven Blake boy we'll
already have the story of a senator's
legislative director in the wrong
woman's car with a snout full of booger
sugar bger sugar so these charges
they're not just going to get swept
under the rug we're not going to let
them one no way why cuz we don't like
you I don't even know why you're here
we're here cuz we want to know
everything there is to know about little
wi fly on I don't know nothing little wi
is just a code name for what for a new
technology currently in devel velopment
incredible anti-missile software atomic
bomb but a certain Aeronautics company
approached us let me guess New Age yeah
buddy they found the software could be
tweaked it could be used in missiles and
not just against them it could be scaled
down and installed in portable shoulder
fired surface to air Weaponry Jesus
allows missiles to defeat all known
counter measures oh damn so we're
dealing with like like fullon arms
dealers yeah and weapons optimized to
never fail completely bypass their
target making Pilots believe the threat
has passed and then they recalibrate
turn around zero back in on the aircraft
and reack like in dead the project
required an appropriation Bill Lavoy
knew Little Wing would slingshot our
military into the future so I'm assuming
Lavoy didn't clear up the red tape in
the most reputable manner what do you
mean I helped bury the proposal in a
thousand page statute while Lavoy shook
hands and drummed up votes and he did
this out of the the goodness of his
heart to protect democracy fat envelopes
slipped inside newspapers on park
benches grow the up
okay everyone made fun of the Star Wars
defense program but look at where we are
now everyone's trying to shoot
projectiles out of the air Little Wing
can knock anything out of the sky wow
it's actually space force your jackass
yeah get it right new H has two bases
software made in New York Hardware at a
manufacturing plant in Denver
Colorado no man there's a lot of like
crazy military [__] that goes on
Colorado I believe it welcome everyone
to Olivia and Greg's wedding here in
beautiful below 0 deg
Colorado so are the drug charges getting
dropped or what I don't know I'm not a
cop nice L of a surprise hearing you're
wearing the badge again Lieutenant no
less yeah well retirement didn't suit me
good see you're still sporting the
Tweed what was it you told me when we
first met trouble always seems to find
you amen you kill a whole lot of people
here and there you still spin in that
wedding ring got a new one here and
there a feeling better every day and the
dog Jack eat too
much the dog dog's back or doing well
what are our directives you dicks and go
to Denver Ling software is useless
without the missile hardware and that's
where it's made who's tailing us Odon
and I will head down to DC want to swing
by Homeland see what they know about am
you swing by Homeland I think we're just
going to knock on the door and say can
the dod come out and play my brother
worked for Homeland his contacts can
help us that's right forgot about that
how's Joe doing these days he's dead
yeah covered him
Dixon I feel an action scene is coming
do you I do I thought they were going to
crash the car or someone was going to
crash into them a minute ago so yeah you
going to throw it in the garbage like
our sociopathic friend here borrow it oh
yeah here you
go are just going to fight a random
biker game yeah we heard you're the
biggest guy in town and we're here to
establish
dominence hand over your guns what makes
you think we have guns we were told
you'd be packing Reacher packing Reacher
pack reach he beat us he did it for us
yeah they also tell you you die
tonight they said you were smart I'm
going to cut you got you you don't mess
with the oneth man haven't you heard oh
yes yeah don't mess with the special
investigators
[__] hell
yeah boy oh yeah he's got the
nucks no does he have him right now he's
always got him with his paw patrol
Band-Aids damn perfectly timed Deni oh
good
elbow chain is such a cool weapon and he
just damn damn the way she uses them
elbows are
[Music]
great he head butt it broke his
elbow God and that leg Bend
oh double leg Bend why are you hurting
them so
much well they got pipes and chains and
[__] I guess it's even
oh
no no not the hot one in the dress yes
with
heal she said she was going to do it to
somebody what a brutal ass fight or I
guess NE said it but still someone
delay good stunt
work damn that was a brutal
fight yeah before you ask if it's done
it is
you're causing a very complex operation
a lot of problems $65 Million worth
Langston assume that's who I'm talking
to at a
security why don't we make a deal I have
the means to give you anything you could
ask for what is it that you want
oh I want to throw you out of a
helicopter yeah
dude I would have asked for four to five
dogs but whatever but five dogs and then
I throw you out of the helicopter not a
house I want a rental yeah under a
different name give me a an airliner and
I'll just haul it on my back I like the
use of the music this episode too yeah
man yeah dude I got a lot of positive
thoughts on that one I generally do I
really do but not before I get out the
positive thoughts oh on today's video SP
thank you to Shopify for sponsoring
which is what we use news for our merch
store and is our gamechanging partner in
eCommerce so whether you're launching a
passion project or scaling to new
heights Shopify is e-commerce Powerhouse
guiding you at every step from creating
your first online store to opening
physical locations Shopify makes it
seamless it's perfect whether you're
selling exclusive merch or unique
Collectibles thanks to their
all-encompassing platform for both
online and inore sales their checkout
system unmatched it's 36% more effective
at converting visitors into buyers than
other platforms and let's not forget
Shopify magic the AI to that elevates
your business with minimal effort but
seriously reflecting on your journey
using Shopify for www.re naations
shop.com it's been transformative the
transition smooth growth exponential
thank you again reject Nation from
simplifying sales to scaling our
offerings Shopify has been a Cornerstone
of our success and Shopify isn't just
for us it Powers 10% of us e-commerce
backing businesses big and small and
over 10075 countries there a war-winning
support always there to guide you so
ready to join the revolution sign up for
Shopify at only a dollar a month at
shopify.com reex all overc case
shopify.com reex start your Shopify
success story now let's grow together
with Shopify team big thanks to
expressvpn for sponsoring this video a
real game changer I've been using for
years that's right years so whenever
they want to work with us it's an
instant yes you've likely heard about
expressvpn for online privacy and
security but there's more to it than
that however there was a very real
incident recently with Spectrum Shing
down my internet and contacting me due
to a suspecting hacking attempt and
funny enough I realized I hadn't
actually activated my expressvpn on my
new laptop that I got a couple of months
ago so I was paying the consequences
having faced a serious hacking issue on
YouTube a couple years ago that made
expressvpn my go-to for both security
and freedom I mean it and yes what you
heard is true believe me this channel
knows you can use expressvpn to watch
movies and shows on Netflix that are not
available in your country this means
accessing a vast rate of content of over
100 countries like a global Cinema your
fingertips it's super easy open Express
VPN switch locations refresh the browser
and there you have it whether it's
kdramas on South Korean Netflix Hulu BBC
I player YouTube or more expressvpn has
you covered and it's incredibly fast
ensuring no buffering or lack for smooth
HD streaming it's versatile too working
on not just computers but phones media
consoles Smart TVs and more this means
you can enjoy your favorite shows at
anywhere any screen protect and elevate
your internet experience so if you want
to get access to hundreds of new shows
use my link expressvpn.com reex and you
can get an extra 3 months of expressvpn
for free that's
expressvpn.com rejects so head to
expressvpn.com reex to learn more thank
you again I really like this one a lot
that's my favorite one of the season so
far favorite yet yeah it really brought
it's because we had a returning
character from season one yeah I didn't
like any of this until Finley showed up
like it all makesense now if you just
get Rosco oh wow oh dude you never know
you never know you never know what could
happen endless possibilities of
Television PR Endless
Possibilities uh no even before that I
was it was Dawning on me in the way they
bicker in the restaurant at that very
opening scene that they are the best
ones to cast out in Reacher's mind you
know because they know him the best so
he feels simultaneously the most
comfortable yet they can Pro poke and
prod him the way that uh could hit a
soft spot better than anyone else
whereas you know last season you're
exposed to a bunch of characters where
you just know he's in like in control
he's in charge and whatever they have to
say about him probably wrong yeah they
probably have no idea whereas these are
the people you got pain Reacher what is
it underneath that pain you know other
than that yeah so this is like people
who definitely respect and look up to
him but also have been with him long
enough to to be able to see him in a way
most people can't yeah because as much
as he's the leader of the operation he
still wants to always be equal with them
so the way they like uh just with each
other I think is really strong so yeah
no I me I I really felt like the core
chemistry of the cast really Shine the
Light I feel like it finally caught up
to my emotions here yeah and the that's
a really big mystery at hand last one
was you know a small town smuggling or
whatever and don't really remember the
details and this one's like we could
destroy a country you
know we could we could any Target we won
we could win any War this is like much
bigger uh much bigger money at play as
well so it it's it's cool though I I I
liked everything uh about this one I
thought the chemistry was solid I like
watching them out in the field being
undercover and then of course getting
the down and dirty fight at the end like
we a lot of the things that I I've not
been diving into the comments admittedly
on Reacher one and two two one through
three reaction only because I know how
these things go all right I see the way
audiences are loving things and here we
are having like yeah we're enjoying it
but we're not as in love with it I know
that I qu so we getting a lot of crap in
the comments so I'm like why would I
waste my why would I expose myself to
that
unnecessarily and and uh there's one
thing to like engage and have a
discussion with a discourse or whatever
it's another thing when you're diving in
through a plethora of YouTube comments
that I'm just going to assume are there
U and and I I'll say though that the
emotion get people killed ions do get
people killed you need all the details
yes or whatever what's the line Details
Matter Details Matter I I think and then
had a realization that details do matter
in investigation oh my God guys there
are these whole things called
Clues all assembled of these details is
that what you call
them explain to me specifically in depth
what is a detail what do you mean
there's not just one detail there are
many kinds of detail how many details do
I have to keep track of is there a
finite number of details break it down
to me at its molecular core what is a
detail bring me a definitive detail so I
can just understand the basic
[Laughter]
principle you can't just look at
anything and say it's a detail that's
the point of detail no Details Matter uh
they do they do everything is the
details oh yeah yeah that that was
really that was I just like I I don't
know I just really like the style I felt
kind of that New York Vibe and and it
felt like there was a kind of a more
unique personality to it I wasn't even
like thinking about the action until we
got to the moment where oh I feel like
an action scene's coming yeah I think
that's I think in the most simplified
way that is what I often hope for from
this show in particular a show like this
is yeah to be engrossed no matter what
is happening and to be just as engrossed
by the you know relationships and the
figuring out of the mystery even if some
of that figuring out is you know very
kind of Rapid Fire and details are sort
of like oh you got to grab like there's
certainly moments where and we joke
during the episode and yes if we were
completely silent throughout the entire
thing it might be easier to catch every
little detail but those moments this
video would also constantly get blocked
in copyright yes and there would be very
little footage C wa yeah exactly so you
know uh but yeah like those moments
where people would clarify I got a I
mean I I real it dawned on me yesterday
I got interrupt and part of the
interruption is what I'm going to say
is what's the rest of the interruption
just this part explaining it is that uh
I you know I were you officially
diagnosed yet ADHD or add were you
actually diagnosed or were you just
suspected I was like yes I've been
diagnosed twice yes that's how I know
for yes after much going around with
many many professionals what do you have
ADHD okay yeah I've been diagnosed with
ADH depression anxiety here are all my
issues well I wasn't asking for the
whole like problem history John I Wasing
about one thing Jesus dial it back you
were asking about Jesus it's your victim
Jesus was the Savior born in
Bethlehem right around this time of year
except really in April we is that uh
this fast thinking mind is I we have a a
our mind is constantly thinking of
things all the time it doesn't stop
doesn't turn off we're like creater that
way and and we're able to utilize that
VI reaction the things that we often
Reserve to ourselves out of politeness
and knowing that in regular day-to-day
viewing experiences for individuals that
we would just get on their nerves with
the amount of thoughts that we'd be
sharing we now have an excuse to
actually get that out of our system yes
because a that's what is going through
our mind and heart and B it gives
something to cut away to to feature the
reaction to get the requisite 8 to 10
seconds you're only allowed for a clip
so yeah yeah and and and we also I mean
you know these are all happening off the
to maintain the sanctity of the first
reaction you know these are all just
whatever were whatever we got in the
moment so you better hope you got good
observations good commentary good Joker
and good rhymes for Jack Reacher in the
moment yeah man and sometimes all I saw
was the top comment of the last one and
I said I am not going through the
Wormhole of these comments yes yes no
and that was all about they run out of
puns I even cut out the whole thing
about when you said Jack crowbar the
whole thing was cut out of when I was
like crowbar John what hasn't even what
is there's not even a rhyme there yes
Jack Reacher and Jack crowbar aren't
that far away because they don't rhyme
they're in the same meter but we have
established but but okay we have EST you
must admit Jack Reacher and Jack poacher
don't rhyme just because there's a chur
at the end doesn't make those Rhymes
though
so like it's really hard to get because
you always need an eer rhyme to make it
truly rhyme they rhyme better than
crobar agree to disagree how does
crowbar because it still ends in an R
it's still a two- syllable word and so
like wow I didn't realize orange and
St and it still has Jack
Jack on camera
here I mean I'm going to employ a little
bit of his words y because people Revere
his technical ability and will accept
that rhymes can exist where they're not
most obviously presenting themselves and
some of them yes are going to be Duds
some of them are just not going to be
amazing and I regret we have I'm saying
we have
established we have established through
a whole season one that when we are pun
rhyming that's obviously very much like
obvious one syllable or the two a very
clear distinctive one syllable Rhyme or
a two- syllable rhyme it's like Jack
Flack slack Rack Attack I'm giving you
once to hold on to for the future here
attack is a two word yes but it's the
ACT part that the average listener is
going to pick up you you know don't I'm
just saying there's more ways to
do we are dealing with YouTube b
is fair enough I'll keep it Anthony F T
we not this is that's not who I'm
drawing my pun game from yeah but I
think he can make an argument cuz he's
talking about music and lyrics we're
making stupid jokes that ride with Jack
time now independent of my viewership of
the needle drop Channel I have ascribed
to the theory that poetry can be poetic
without rhyme so like I'm making the
effort to at least try and and make it
like relevant to or rhymable in a way
but like it doesn't always have to be a
rhyme to to equate to word player poetry
I agree so I'm just going to stick to
chur on a fundamental level I agree go
for a e the way it is being conveyed to
the audience sure as the top voted
comment yeah no I mean I'll take it I'll
after a while you can't just blame
everyone else I'm not going to anymore
intern go something that we are looking
that's the
challenge but yes I know shouldn't we
challenge the
audience these J these stupid silly
jokes wor they're challenging by Me by
me coming down on this I guarantee you
whoever made it this far there will be
comments being like I'm with John on
this one that's all I that's all we've
done we've opened the door man but but
in seriousness fine like I'll take the
note we needed the conversation in the
attempt to pun and I'll only release the
cream of the crop no I held back on Happ
we needed to have the that would that
would weirdly work that would work a
good it doesn't need to be it can be
four syllables but if it ends in a chur
we've accomplished it so the CH is the
real key to the ride I really think it
is
honest for the average listener accept I
will accept that that may that those are
the you were like oh I want to I want to
learn how to write a rap I think people
would start with that kind of mentality
right they would look at the chur but I
agree I think they will quickly learn
that if they only use the chur as the
rhyme they will soon go well the first
halves of all these words are like
totally different and it's not as
impressive because a million words end
in chur just like there's
beser well anyone who's doing anybody
who does an activity is an ER of some
kind or like
weaker yeah Bleaker peer sneaker yeah so
those I think I don't think has a chur
but you can add ER to anything is my
point I know I know I made that point in
last season when you were pulling that
[__] and I said no John we must
challenge the
audience it's an Ora
Boris well I have some positive thoughts
on the
episode it doesn't matter anymore we're
done I will I will manage
the on the puns definitely talk so much
more about I will try and bring my
better better game to that however all
we have to do is bring it up and then
now you have a rise of defenders in your
corner and now we can do both secret way
to to yeah call engagement for these
videos uh no I really liked this episode
and I agree I I
liked I was happy with the episode and
I'll find a way to shoehorn that into
the next reaction I didn't mean to Flack
Reacher you here Sean it's okay man uh I
I take it back Reacher anything I might
have said to uh you know defy oh oh I
just thought of a good one for oh okay
uh feel I don't forget it but I thought
of a perfect one I'll just say it would
have been great for when when Jack and
Dixon were doing it in the bedroom ooh
okay come on do you know
what I think so do you want me to to
levy my
guess I mean yes okay uh riddle me this
how clean is it because I have a clear
idea I think works because they were in
the sack Reacher that's it okay all
right all right all right all right good
then we yes that is a good one all right
next do it at scene sack
Reacher yes call her here uh but but uh
you know to get back Reacher to
discussing Reacher episode for I no I I
this has been a steady kind of incline
of yeah it's taken these each episode
seems to clarify kind of what the season
is going for and I'm getting more and
more on board with that as we go and
this episode had the best like calcified
Ensemble like I was really getting into
like you said the rhythm of all of the
main four of them and uh and yeah even
though there are so many of these
details that are like a lot to keep
track of and you've got these names of
companies and and you know different
incidental characters and then different
important characters and things like
that it's thought uh the way that they
hardened by deposition or conversion
into calcium carbonate or another
insoluble calcium compound uh oh I you
know something is made material
something is like made does that fit am
I misusing this word say read read the I
was trying to correct you I don't I
didn't know what it meant so look at
that well now I want to see if I used it
right Hardon by deposition or conversion
into calcium carbonate or another I was
going to type it on the computer but
yeah it's like something BEC reasonably
far away solidified uh maybe somebody a
vocab nerd can jump in but yeah it's
like their chemistry and their Dynamic
gets more solid the more time chemistry
John the purest chemistry uh
Johnny let the actors cook uh yeah like
all the four main ones uh you don't
spend that much time with the cop but I
like again him whenever he busts through
I'm always pleased to see him and
there's always I can feel the scene he's
having even though he's off screen like
whenever he pops in and he's like pissed
off at them I'm like I can see what your
day is probably like such a New Yorker
yeah and I love that and and I'm really
enjoying that as part of this because
like we're not spending that much time
like soaking up the city and part of me
I I waver on that CU part of me is like
we've done New York in all of Cinema a
billion trillion bazillion times and so
even though part of me is like would be
cool to see like how this world immerses
in it I I feel like we still are in a
way especially going into like Upper
Crust politics and things like that and
then well I think fish out of water is a
natural is like I think one of the best
audience hooks you can ever do sure you
know because even if you're Jack Reacher
who's Mr
Mystery Mr in control yeah yeah uh
because he's still Fish Out of Water
there's something where you are on the
journey with him because fish Out of
Water yeah and and um they have
completely removed that
element yeah out outside of what's
Happening Here guys you know it's not
really a fish out of water yeah he he he
sticks out everywhere but not in the
same way he did back in Mar grave in New
York no one's going to be like whoa look
at the giant walking what Beast stalk
did you fall out of yeah yeah he he
Blends in a bit more and I think it's a
nice fun kind of subtle
choice to yeah bring in his peers who
can see him and and who can foil him in
a way we're not used to seeing him
foiled so much in in an emotional sense
more than a yeah a physical or an even
like cunning sense at least that we know
of so far well I love how much they
question him and how much it seemed to
really make you could see in Alan Rich's
performance yeah
that what is it uh he he doesn't waver
in his in his belief when he believes
he's you know in when he feels like he's
right about something yeah I know the
content of Swan's character I don't
believe he would go this way no matter
what but he gave enough of a shade of a
doubt in his performance to show and
only this team could kind of get to him
on that yeah and it shows the the that
yeah it's like that's a a a a well-worn
it's like it's been built up over so
much time so it's not like fragile in
that sense but it is like yeah this is a
tenuous line
you know casting doubt on one of our own
freaking yeah it's tempestuous man [__]
it's all right uh but yeah like M there
just the fact like he's so adamant
against it but he's also not
like uh like flying off the handle but
he's still just kind of taking the
feedback and not like completely shading
the team or making it some kind of
meltic thing it's like he's clearly
steadfast in his belief in his gut
instinct about you know the things that
are going on the circumstances um but
yeah I like the way they handle those
Shadows of doubt and especially in this
episode I thought it got pretty
engrossing as to just like yeah what
okay so clearly these two companies are
together I want to believe that Swan you
know sees the risk that uh this little
wing program presents right right and uh
and you know is trying to you know send
messages from the inside the Hendrick
thing um you know and you hope for that
and I have to feel like because he looks
so suspicious in that scene where
they're at the car with the bricks and
they're like Hey where's this extra
brick of drugs that just like fell out
into the you know space below your seat
I guess like yeah it's it's I I like the
way this episode breath failed to uh
track Reacher hey failed to track reach
of the drugs under the back seat this is
being used in the review this is so it
is allowed to be used again in further
reactions yes it's a touchstone back to
the moment in the episode yeah it makes
yeah it's these are these are appendix
we will act like we thought of them for
the first time there yeah totally
totally totally yeah if you stick around
for the reviews next reaction you know
you'll feel a little included on some
special [__] um but yeah uh I like all
that stuff and I like the am am guy even
though it is the most broad part of this
particular story
in a story that again not to keep being
like the first season but like they seem
to establish that the tone of the show
wants things to be pretty tangible
pretty real and that's part of the fun
is that Jack Reacher and his crew but
especially Jack come off kind of super
in some way like oh man like yeah this
guy is a a big buff Sherlock Holmes of
sorts um but uh uh uh oh goodness I had
a train of thought just like totally you
were saying that Jack showering in the
bathroom is one of like Life's greatest
cinematic things ever the the broadness
yeah like it it even like even though
there is still like a magic in a certain
level of height to what the show is
doing uh it is like kind of beyond the
sort of
realism that they seem to want to
maintain when it is like I'm in I need
to do I need to figure my way out of
this identity pickle bus bench guy just
going to immediately go see him I'm
going to immediately kill him and then
I'm going to take his glasses and I'm
going to leave you got to think about
the timeline of it guys we got a problem
no I've got a
solution yeah I'm going to kill this man
take his identity I get myself out of
this predicament yeah this plan will be
delayed by a couple days I just need
enough time to find a good person who
looks just like me to assume their
identity and like I enjoy the thing is
luckily I enjoy it's funny cuz we were
just watching on patreon Supernatural
and it almost made me think of that cuz
there's an episode where there's a
scenario that seems like they're going
to do a fake twin brother Neil um yeah
fake twin brother they're going to do
Nephilim uh and they were going to do a
Nephilim yes I thought he was going to
summon a Nephilim that's right rip a
hole in time and space find an alternate
Dimension where like Jack reer like this
am guy is something else oh boy yeah
yeah
uh but no it's it's one of those things
that's like it's a Trope and especially
it's a film Noir thing or at least to me
it reminds me of stuff like dark passage
where it's like oh you know the The
Drifter who's either a pi or or a Hitman
or whatever who CH got his face changed
like I I appreciate the tradition of
Noir storytelling that comes from but at
the same time it is very much like it
kind of
undercuts I'm I'm not sure actually I
don't know it gives this Mystique 2 a.m.
and so like it's it's kind of Broad and
he's so good at what he does and he's
always cool and calm and he's got the
comic books and stuff like that so like
there's a lot of details and flavors
around that character but it is still
like the most kind of broad element and
I think it's still it's not taking me
out too much because it's not the
majority of what we're watching um right
now the only thing that I would say is
you know I think expecting to fear for
Jack Reacher is life is uh a ridiculous
ask of the audience like I would never
impose that feeling onto myself or
anyone else um fear for who he loves yes
or who he's concerned about cares about
and right now if any of them died on the
team I'd be
like that's sad but if someone came up
and shot Finley yeah I'll would be so
hate crime what is this stop everything
and go kill that guy yeah uh I would I I
would I I I I wouldn't like ne's one but
the others actually you know I'm
breaking it down I'm like pretty bummed
if Dixon died honestly I'm getting to
the point where I'd be bummed if Dixon
or o Donell died yeah and O'Donnell with
the dad qualiity I think really and
O'Donnell in this episode was was
particularly fun but also showed his
worth as I started saying it I was
imagining them ding I was like hey
actually you know what I guess I'm out
of not none of of them to the degree I I
guess that is the one thing because I
was there really early on for for neie
and and Rosco and first season yeah
where if any of them died or or like
they I was so concerned for them and
because you're not concerned for Jack
Reacher's life but they them I was
concerned for yeah and with these guys
like it's their lives who are on the
line and I'm still nowhere near there I
won't be devast yeah I would be bummed I
will care but it is the thing where I
feel like this season has had a more
kind of steady build alongside the
immediacy of the mystery and again the
circumstances make sense to why but I
feel like in the first season you had
more pronounced introductions to
characters uh whereas here yeah
everyone's kind of crashing together and
they're like we're doing this kind of
mid investigation so it just moves
different and that's fine like I don't
mind that and I'm liking this
increasingly so I assume that by the end
you know I might love this in a whole
kind of different way from the first and
I and I like when contrast like that can
happen and I am happy to give a show
like this that kind of patience to
develop that uh yeah it's I would like
to be at a point soon where I'm like no
and when I and when we go to season
three then be like you know I think back
on Rosco and Finley and those characters
and I want to think back on these guys
if we don't see anybody other than I
assume neie will kind of be a through
line until she want
I guess I'm just not as super
emotionally invested in any of them yet
but I am this was the like I I I was
noticing like oh when we're cutting away
from Reacher I'm actually really
enjoying it yeah yeah yeah and it was
the first time that it was really
occurring for me uh with this cast of
characters so yeah no I I'm still I'm
still having a lot of fun and I'm really
enjoying and this to me was fun engaging
and overall uh more the Jack reer show
that I I was really grew very fond of
but guys what do you think about it
leave your thoughts down below be sure
to leave a like subscribe thank you to
our sponsors uh we'll talk to you all
soon
bye clap
Reacher no John no that
[Music]
works